for any Theory why this Theory you can't
simply say well we want a pure Big Bang
if you look at the history of
mathematics where these ideas about
mathematical structures come from they
often come from two sources from from
physics in the physical world and then
from number Theory and it turned out
that um that the guy's doing not good
science ended up doing great science and
I think that that's where we are now
[Music]
thank you
the key justification for using a theory
for the evolution of the universe is
that it has to be simple it has to be a
simple explanation for the observations
that we have today so what physicists
have done to replace this problem with
the singularity of the Big Bang is that
they have replaced part of this
Evolution law
early in the universe so you take the
normal Big Bang Theory up to a certain
moment in time uh depends on exactly how
you want to do it then you add a
different Evolution law and you use this
Evolution or to go back uh further in
time this gives you a different initial
State and it can get rid of the
singularity and it can kind of have all
kinds of other consequences
so you change the equations and then as
I said you'd always get an initial state
that then fits together with those
equations to give you what we actually
observe and there are lots of different
theories that have come out of this for
example there may not have been a big
bang there might have been a big bounce
so there was an earlier Universe which
contracted and then it didn't go to your
Singularity but it just shrunks to a
very small size and then it began to
expand again there could be Cycles Roger
Penrose for example has a model for a
cyclic cosmology there's an idea that's
called asymptotic silence well basically
the early Universe I was just sitting
there for a really really long time not
doing anything and then suddenly it
decided it had expand this also gets rid
of the singularity there's the no
boundary proposal from Heartland Hawking
where you basically get rid of time time
entirely so there's only space four
dimensions of space
something maybe there was neither space
nor time there was just a pre-geometric
face maybe some kind of a big Network
that had to condense into a form where
it would give rise to something that
approximate space time to a very good
Precision five dimensional black hole
string yes and so on and so forth it's
it's a really long list but those ideas
all work the same way you change the
evolution law
somewhere back in time and then you have
a different initial state
now what's the problem with this
um well as I said a good scientific
explanation must be simpler than the
observation it's trying to explain and
the problem with all those theories for
the mo for the early universe is that
they make a simple story more difficult
but a good scientific explanation should
be as simple as possible and you
shouldn't add any unnecessary
assumptions no matter how much you would
like there to be a cyclic Universe it
says as LaPlace put it I I had no use
for this hypothesis we also don't really
have use for the hypothesis of an
infinite number of Cycles it's
absolutely unnecessary to explain what
we currently observe
and so this is why I say all those
stories they're basically
Tales the creation myths written in the
language of mathematics they're mostly
not wrong in the sense that all those
physicists I mean it's not like they're
dumb right they make a big effort to get
a theory that actually agrees with
observations of course I mean there are
some people who argue that this or that
idea doesn't actually fit with
observations but that's a little bit
beside the point
mostly they're trying to actually get
the observations out right
so they're not wrong but we can't tell
that they're right because they just add
this unnecessary structure at a time
where we don't actually have any data
[Music]
but I want to get back to the the basic
theme which is you know is the standard
model the Big Bang in trouble
the contrast is basically between a
theory that requires imaginary entities
that are made up after the fact which my
colleagues seem to express a good deal
skepticism about
you can't simply say well we want a pure
Big Bang without inflation without dark
energy without dark matter because the
theory collapses these were introduced
to prevent to overcome severe
conflicts with observation if you don't
have inflation then the theory predicts
a microwave background that would be
completely crazy quilt it wouldn't be at
all even if you don't have dark energy
you have a problem that the universe is
older is younger than the Milky Way
galaxy if you don't have dark matter the
universe can't form any uh
you know clusters or galaxies at all it
doesn't form structure so you can't
simply say well we want the pure one
without all this fairy dust in contrast
what we are talking about is an
alternative that relies on verified
laboratory uh evidence and conversely
theories that are developed for uh
astrophysics can be applied here on
Earth and I want to again come back to
our own work as an example
40 years ago I developed a model of
quasars based on phenomena that observed
in a device called the dense plasma
Focus which spontaneously forms without
gravitation extremely dense plasmoids
very energy concentrated
Blobs of plasma that emit beams of
energy just like a quasar I developed
this model quantitatively applied it to
Quasar data and then used it to design a
version of our device with that device
we achieved seven years ago record
confined temperatures that have never
been achieved in any Fusion experiment
temperatures of 2 billion degrees which
is about 200 times the temperature at
the center of the Sun this is the sort
of confirmation of lab tested results
that we have to use to explain the
universe if we go and say it's okay that
we have all these challenges or tensions
that are our plane has crashed so many
times as long as we can introduce Dark
Matter dark energy or my favorite
cannibal dark matter which has been
proposed to resolve some of these
questions that's not doing science
that's expose facto explanation sort of
just cell stories
[Music]
so by material I think of objects in
space and time
and physicists such as David Gross and
Nema arkani Hamed are now telling us
that space-time is doomed by that they
mean space-time is not fundamental
and they're not just throwing up their
hands and giving up the physicists have
now found structures Beyond space-time
like the positive grossmanian the
amplitudehedron and there so this this
is all new that's only been in the last
10 years that they've for example had
the amplitahedron but the idea that
space and time and objects like um
bosons leptons and quarks particles and
so forth are fundamental is now no
longer the received opinion um there's
something deeper like the amplitohedron
and beyond that something called
decorative permutations and so so the
idea of reductionism is also doomed
according to physicists like Neymar
Connie Ahmed the idea that is we go to
smaller and smaller scales in space and
time we find more and more fundamental
laws and more and more fundamental
entities that's also dead
so so I'm not a pan psychist in the
sense that I don't want to try to put
Consciousness in the elementary
particles because the the physicists
themselves tell us that space-time and
the so-called Elementary particles are
doomed we have to go entirely outside of
space-time and and trying to put
Consciousness inside of particles or
behind particles we have we have to have
a much deeper framework now evolution by
natural selection also agrees this is
work that I've done with some of my
colleagues it also agrees that um our
perceptions of space and time are not an
insight into the nature of reality
they're they're merely an uh an
interface an artifact of our of our
perceptual sensory systems there's a
technical question what is the
probability that Evolution would shape
sensory systems to see any aspect of the
structure of reality as it is and it
turns out the probability is precisely
zero that any sensory system has ever
been shaped to see any aspect of the
structure of objective reality so
Evolution and the physicists agree
space-time is doomed and and
reductionism is doomed and so we have to
look for a theory of Consciousness
outside of it and and I would agree with
with Sam that solipsism is not the
answer either we we needed a theory of
Consciousness that's not solipsistic
foreign
[Music]
I think the observations on the critique
that I can come forth with is
historically based it's philosophically
based and it's trying to take an outside
Observer look in terms of possibility
of how well do we actually know how all
these things stack together but it's not
my role to judge the Merit of a
scientific theory that is for the
scientific community that is one
consequence of physics and philosophy
sort of breaking breaking apart so right
now we have a cosmologist or a scientist
more generally speaking are setting all
the terms
for how to approach and understand the
universe and they're also the ones who
judge whether they think a theory has
more Merit or not to some degree the
core of the model is taken as a matter
of faith
and that if you are to question it
then you risk running a foul of a lot of
things regarding you know funding and
career and and so on
on the one hand especially if you are a
scientist you can build a career now on
challenging some of the upper blocks so
to speak for example Dark Matter there
is a real Challenger to this particular
part
but uh I find very few scientists are
willing to look at the more questionable
assumptions underneath the core building
blocks of how we got here in the first
place and the reason why it strikes me
is not uh because those blocks are so
solid and proven Beyond doubt when you
look at them closely it's more that if
you are to
put them into doubt or if they are
slightly wrong or if you're to remove
them then you lose the guiding structure
you have to make sense of the universe
it's like taking a framework away from a
scientist is the same as making them
blind like then we have nothing to guide
us by so I think that there is a there's
a tendency to want to cling on to the
basics because it becomes very difficult
to do scientific research it is much
more convenient to add things to the
model
and preserve the existing structure than
it is to radically rethink it it's one
of the legacies of the split between
philosophy and Science in the 20th
century is a strand of thought sometimes
called logical empiricism or positivism
which really greatly influence science
into this Rise Of The Professional
School of of science is to believe that
science has to be free of metaphysics
and that it's the ideal is to have a
science that's uh pure without having to
make any such grounding claims or any
such framing devices so
in my view this is a delusion uh and it
would be much better if we could speak
openly about what the guiding
assumptions or the premises for a theory
are and speaking them openly instead of
trying to hide them away if you look at
scientific texts or any scientific
calculation if you look at Einstein's
own work on general relativity he has a
couple of pages describing the
assumptions or the principles that he
uses and then there's pages of
mathematical equations
now most physicists would be trained to
look at his math and then to train to
look at the field equations
and to kind of gloss over the
assumptions part but all of those
assumptions are themselves uh Up For
Debate or questionable they're ways of
framing the problem and I don't think
you can ever get around that
[Music]
in the sort of mid 20th century
Feynman schwinger tomanaga Dyson and
most particular guy named Ken Wilson
came up with a program called
renormalization Theory renormalization
Theory effectively
taught us if you have a flawed Theory
how to make sure that the flaws don't
infect all of your answers so as long as
you have a flawed Theory make sure that
you have like a flaw in the numerator
and the exact same flaw in the
denominator whatever that flaw is you
may not be able to discern it but at
least you can cancel it
right so it's similar for example to
Black Shoals pricing where you have a
security and you have an option on the
security whatever the uncertainty is
it's the same uncertainty in both and so
you should be able to hold one long one
short and you end up with a risk-free
bond that doesn't because price doesn't
vibrate
this uh this trick in some sense uh
humbled the physicists and they started
to realize that all of their theories
were sort of trapped within an energy
regime and they were afraid to guess
outside of their energy regime because
Wilson taught them what could be what
could be lurking but my belief is that
um that's the wrong lesson if you ever
watch like Wheel of Fortune you know
they spin the wheel and they have to
guess like a phrase and you see a very
long phrase and somebody says uh
you know is there a p and there is a p
uh
and says can I guess you're like well
you only have one letter she says look
before you leap oh my God that's true
um we've got to guess and the physicists
learned the wrong lesson in my opinion
which is uh it's not enough to determine
the answer but that doesn't mean you
can't guess and it doesn't mean you
shouldn't guess and I actually think uh
the dear Lord that you and I don't
believe in
uh has left a large number of clues that
are sort of subtle right because like in
that situation it's it's the letter
pattern that really determines that
those those anomalous guesses and
they're they're likelihood of being
right we can use far less information
than you would imagine to to actually
guess if the theory has order this was
of course the problem with the double
helix by Rosalind Franklin didn't get it
is that she was being a good scientist
and she was saying we don't have enough
information to guess it's a helix
were not good scientists they were great
scientists who weren't very good and the
difference between good and great is is
the great on honestly realizes that you
have to break the simplistic rules of
science to make an advance sometimes so
they said let's only search for helices
and she thought well you guys are just
mimicking Linus pollen because you're
wannabes you're thirsty and you're
trying to get a something like the alpha
Helix in protein and it turned out that
um the guy's doing not good science
ended up doing great science and I think
that that's where we are now
foreign
[Music]
research I did have this amazing dream
where I had this vision of this equation
and then when I woke up I could think
what was it and of course since then I'm
a teacher I teach in a state school
um my feeling that I'm glad actually
because from the perspective of students
it seems very arrogant
um and sort of superior to think that
you could Encompass all of this amazing
world and then you know plants leaves
have been embracing quantum mechanics
long before we found out anything about
it you know to Fred's in size haven't
they so yeah and students you know my
passion is about enabling them to do
amazing stuff and they can and yet with
this sort of it sort of permeates across
education we have a very boring way of
making sure that they don't really get
excited by the aww and wonder of physics
you know we teach them very boring
models of the solar system to model the
atom when actually they should be
realizing that there's no such thing as
position and sort of an essence of
quantum mechanics I'll do a quick poll
Who Loved physics at school
all the parts I'm completely wrong then
so I practically have a fire storage
just a bitter but um you know if we are
set in thinking there are set ways then
there's very limit huge limits on
particularly young people to think that
there are Avenues open for them for
example only 10 of string theories are
women
um and we know what the trouble is about
the lack of women in physics uh also
other sorts of modes of thought you know
why is it that we've got 10 000 times
the amount of energy that we need
arriving every day from the Sun and yet
we sort of attract in ways of thinking I
was reading about indigenous science
we've you know write that out and lost
some of the amazing understandings how
they built the pyramids and everything
in a science has amazing successes and
of course I love it and I think it's
amazing and can improve the world but I
think we should be having different
views and the opportunities especially
for young people to see that there are
different ways of thinking and that you
don't have to be a certain way to go
down say string theory and totally mad
mathematical physics which nobody can
understand
um and so I feel that I'm quite glad
that perhaps this sort of constraining
idea is waning
foreign
[Music]
people often start with is that the
classical reality that we're used to
when we're seeing everything around us
and this picture of the space with the
stuff in it moving around that we see
that's
you know that's easy to understand the
hard thing to understand is what's
happening at this microscopic level and
I actually like to turn that around I
think from especially when you're
looking at the mathematics of it the
easy thing to understand is the Quantum
level I mean I could write down
schrodiger's equation that I can tell
you very very precisely exactly what is
going on you know with a few particles
behaving in a quantum mechanical level
how once you put 10 in the 23 or
whatever these particles together and
with very complicated physics how the
classical world and what we see and what
we see what we think we understand every
day how that emerges from the quantum
system
that's really really hard to understand
and it's actually behind our kind of
this kind of question about you know how
do you interpret quantum mechanics how
what is a measurement all of those
questions are actually very very
difficult physical questions because
because exactly because of this problem
I think I've sometimes
say that I take kind of a radical
platonistic attitude that not only does
math exist but it really actually is the
same thing as fundamental fundamental
level as physics and and some of the
reasons for saying that are actually
just the experience especially in recent
years
if you look at the history of
mathematics where
these ideas about mathematical
structures come from they often come
from two sources from from physics in
the physical world and then from number
Theory and and traditionally these are
two you know completely different things
that you know the
arguments about despite the example you
gave you've been arguments about prime
numbers or the structure of of number of
numbers and arguments about physical
reality are just completely different
parts of the subject but in recent years
there have been ways in which you can
see these things coming together and
some of the most exciting research is
happening now in mathematics of the
frontiers of mathematics involves ideas
which you know where there's a clear
component of this and just to give a
name to it there's this idea of the
geometrical anglins program and you can
that is something that kind of came out
of number Theory and it but it brought
connections to physics and to geometry
and it's when you're looking at the
deepest level just these connections
between what you thought was purely
mathematical objects and what you
thought was was physics just are just
striking relations that are we're
learning striking things about that
foreign
[Music]
so I think I think you know some people
in say the ladies Which is far before
long before I joined became involved in
this field you know they did overhype
things right they said while this is
going to solve everything and I I have
to say you know maybe it's them but
maybe it's also the media they like this
right
of this
um and so you know of course of course
there's an over promising and you know a
lot of the people in the field were very
I'm told and they tell me were very very
uncomfortable about that instead of
saying you know we have a theory that
might answer some aspects of the
ultimate Theory of Everything Isn't that
cool on its own you know saying wow we
can answer Theory of Everything and
we're going to have a description of
everything in the next 10 or 20 years
which was just promising far too much
and was not going to was not going to
um you know not going to meet people's
expectations so I mean you know I I
actually don't disagree with Peter in
fact about you know the current versions
of quantum gravity theories are very
very poor at describing cosmological
physics so things which are changing
over cosmological time scales and so
we're always extrapolating from our
understanding of in different regimes
and so we're being told that actually
our extrapolation must be wrong but I I
take that as actually interesting
because it's saying well actually we've
got to think about other things we can
do so I've diverted a bit away from your
question but I think you know in the
media there's been almost this over
hyping I think in in the actual
scientific Community it's a much more
measured approach of actually it's one
step forward at a time you know one one
bit at a time and there is progress
um and it's important not to sort of
over promise what you do
[Music]
what I showed was that singularities you
use the word singularities we'll come to
that singularities are a robust
prediction of General activity now you
see the picture we have of a black hole
is you've got a certain
region where things can't get out of
it's called The Horizon so if you fall
through imagine a big sphere that if you
fall through that sphere
there's a point of no return and you
can't ever get back again
and that's the Horizon now the
singularities are right in the middle
and the black hole is basically
why you can't see the synchronizes I
mean what I showed let me get backtrack
a little bit in 19 I get my dates
probably wrong when I say this but 1939
there was a paper written by Oppenheimer
of atomic bomb distinction and all that
stuff
Oppenheimer and Snyder who is a graduate
student I think of his and they studied
a what's called a dust cloud Now dust
means the material has no pressure
and it was a completely specially
symmetrical
it you you have this dust collapsing
inwards now the thing is that first of
all it has no pressure secondly it's
focused exactly at that Central Point so
the fact that it falls in there's
nothing to stop it and the density is
likely to get bigger and bigger and
bigger and become infinite
and this was the picture that
Oppenheimer and Snyder produce at that
time now is that realistic well people
said well first of all it's material has
pressure so
more importantly if you have exact
symmetry then of course there's got
nowhere else to go apart from right to
the center so the fact that you get
Singularity is it's not perhaps a
surprise
foreign
[Music]
and religion aren't at War there are a
lot of people who try to play those two
out against each other but if you look
at what's actually going on in the
foundations of physics that then many of
the ideas that physicists consider there
especially about
the question how the universe began
they're basically extensions of some of
those originally religious or spiritual
ideas that just formulated in the form
of mathematics and there are many of
those
religious ideas which are still
compatible with with all we currently
know there are also some things that may
forever remain unknown I already said I
believe that ultimately we probably
won't be able to figure out how the
universe began because it seems to me
that this is just a way that science is
fundamentally limited that we we aren't
allowed to make a story more complicated
though that may not be wrong like there
may have been a more complicated
Universe before hours it's just that the
way that science works we would never be
able to say whether it was actually
correct
um another question to which we may
never found find an answer is if there's
actually a theory of everything so this
isn't something which I talked about
here in any lengths again that's
something that I talk about in my book
um but to make a long story short
um the problem is they will always
remain the question
for any Theory why this Theory we know
that the Universe has to be in some
particular way I mean we know that it is
some particular way and not any other so
we need a theory that agrees with what
what we observe but then there will
always be questions in this Theory which
we can only answer by saying because it
describes what we observe
so I think this is another way
um that science is fundamentally Limited
[Music]
thank you